Gai news and we start with some breaking
news this hour and reports that a man
has been shot on the street in Stratham
in South London let's speak now to our
home affairs correspondent mark white he
joins us on the phone hello to you mark
what more can you tell us confirm from
sources that police have shot a man in
the street and Stratham that main road
that one through stress in the a23 is
sealed off at the moment has lots of
emergency services are there armed
police on scene as well
sealing off that area making sure it's
safe I can also confirm but several
other people have been injured in this
incident there are reports that they may
have been stabbed I can't confirm that I
can't confirm though that several people
have been injured and one man has been
shot by armed police I'm not sure what
his condition is the moment although
again there are reports circulating wild
widely that this individual may be dead
now but that's not information that I
can confirm at this stage said to say
that this is clearly a significant
incident that's unfolding within the
last hour in this area of South London
there are a number of pictures already
coming through as they always do in the
early stages of these major incidents on
social media and that shows a very
significant presence and attendance from
of course the police but the ambulance
service there as well in the in the
middle of just trying to treat those who
have been injured when there is still
very much an active crime scene people
who are in the area are being told by
the Metropolitan Police to move out of
the area to move away the police
confirming that there is an incident
that they are dealing with in stress and
at the moment and they're asking members
of the public to stay away no net
you